yesterday two school girls and four
women were shot in a drive-by shooting
in London a girl of seven is fighting
for her life and of course this comes
off the back of shootings in Liverpool
Ellie Edwards 25 year old killed
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Cabell
does Britain have a problem with gun
crime well I can't comment on obviously
on this terrible case yesterday there's
obviously a live investigation underway
but look it's one of the reasons why
we've recruited 15 000 more police
officers since 2019 since the election
when we made that commitment and also
we've seen an effect from that in London
for example which is where this latest
case was we've seen the police seizing a
significant number of weapons and we've
seen a reduction in violent crime of
seven percent but obviously each
individual tragedy is terrible and my
thoughts go out to those families
concerned and I know the police will be
looking at this case and making progress
as fast as they can is it too easy for
people to get guns well look we have
incredibly tough laws in this country
um about people not being able to get
guns and obviously it depends on them
but then it obviously depends on on
incredibly good policing which is to say
is why we've recruited more police
officers to make up for the short forms
we've recruited more police officers and
that's why we've seen a reduction in in
violent crime and I hope that a positive
trend continues okay
now teachers have backed
backed for a strike next month uh they
say it's likely to follow the pattern of
the Rel Union and you of course know
more than anyone how disruptive phase
rail strikes have been what impact could
strikes in schools have well look first
of all we don't we don't know that we've
seen some briefing in some newspapers
the only ballot result that we have seen
for for a teacher's Union actually was
that it didn't reach the threshold and
therefore they're not able to I think
that was the nas uwtn not able to
actually go out on strike but clearly
any strikes anything disrupting
children's education will be very
regressible children obviously have
their education disrupted during the
covid pandemic the last thing we want to
see is children's education disrupted
now that's why the education secretary
for example met
um and her team met teachers unions to
talk about the government's evidence the
independent pay review borders and to
listen to the concerns that teachers
have got and that's what the government
wants to do is back to the independent
pay review bodies and it wants to listen
to the concerns that the teacher just
have about you know about education
um I want to talk about the pay with
your body in a moment but you know the
National Education union says that pays
for them by 23 relative to inflation
since 2010. it's a complaint that's
echoed in our Health Service as well we
read today that the nursing Union has
said that twice as many nurses are going
to be walking out in February I mean
what impact could that have on patient
care will safe numbers be maintained
well look I'm on the Health Service
um again we we've put an extra a
significant amount of money into the
Health Service in the Autumn statement
an extra 14 billion pounds and in fact
not just into Health but also
importantly into social care because
that's one of the things that's causing
some of the delays in in a e on pay
we've supported the independent pay
review body so on the Health Service
this is really important there there
were recommendations that for example
would see the starting salary of a nurse
increase by 1400 pounds and we accepted
those recommendations in full and of
course what happened this week again
were ministers met the health unions to
listen to their concerns about pay and
other working conditions and also to
talk about the government's evidence to
the pay review bodies for the
forthcoming year I just want to Deep
dive a little bit into the pay review if
I may because look this is what we
always get from the government that it's
all down to the independent pay review
body that you're accepting the
recommendations I just feel like it's a
bit more complicated than that actually
and so in your letter to them last year
you said it's vital that planned
Workforce growth is Affordable and
within the budget set particularly as
there is a direct relationship between
pay and staff numbers and it's the same
with this year's letter so in this
year's letter you say it has to be
within the budget set and then you go on
to say in the current economic context
it's particularly important that you
also have regard to the government's
inflation Target which is two percent
when forming recommendations so you're
effectively saying look guys this is
what we budgeted per pay if you go over
it people are going to get snacked and
you're going to contribute to inflation
doesn't sound that attendant well no
we've set out the context which is we've
set out what the Health Service budgets
are and as I said we've put an extra 14
billion pounds into that and there are
there are significantly more nurses and
more doctors
you could get their recommendations
first before I think it's unfortunately
what the pay review body say would be a
good idea I think it's important to set
out the context they should know what
the overall economic context is that's
part of the government's evidence the
other thing they look at they're
specifically tasks to look at
Recruitment and Retention so that's one
of the things for example the unions
have said they're concerned about that's
another important thing the pay review
board is look at so they look at
Workforce workforce planning and then of
course they also get evidence in from
the trade unions which will be looking
at it from their perspective so the
pay-per-view body has evidence across
the board of the government's views the
Union's views and then they come to an
independent View and last year that's
what the government accepted and by the
way they've also complained that you
give your evidence so late that they
can't actually really influence it
because your evidence is so late that
the budgets have been set I just want to
have a look at their own response
because the independent pay review
themselves say in settling the
Department of Health and Social care and
the NHS budget which totals 173.8
billion pounds the government assumed a
headline pay Award of two percent for
NHS staff the department has an
additional 1 contingency which is
choosing to make available providing an
overall affordable headline pay Award of
up to three percent so you pretty much
set the parameters don't you you make an
assumption of what they're going to do
and you say look you've got a one
percent contingency here if you don't
then people will get well you have to
make a when you're setting the budget
for the NHS you obviously have to make
some assumptions you could ask them
before you set the budget this is my
point well then you could say this is
what they say should happen on pay let's
form the budget around well if we did
that then what you would do is you'd get
lots of health trusts coming to us
saying we'd set the budgets very late in
the day so look we've said the budgets
for the Health Service we've made some
assumptions but we'll look at what the
independent pay body says and I think
people should judge us by what we've
done in the past last year we accepted
in full the recommendations of that
independent pay-per-view body that's
what we delivered
um and so and that's what led to pay
rises in the NHS in line with the rest
of the economy but which were focused
actually at the lower paid
members of Staff which meant they
actually had larger pay Rises which I
think is the right thing to do
um just before we move on to rail
strikes and with more nurses going on
strike with doctors potentially striking
too
you know you're obviously like a a
politician but you're also human are you
worried about the current situation in
the NHS and could strikes have an impact
on patient safety well look clearly um
when health staff go on uh strike you
know that is obviously going to have an
impact on the Health Service
um we have to put detailed contingency
plans in place uh working with the NHS
and Health Service managers to make sure
we can still deliver
Safe Care even on days when there are
strikes but there is clearly an impact
when significant numbers of Staff don't
come to work what is that impact
well the impact can be seen from the
fact that you know take ambulance
services for example people have to wait
longer for an ambulance to turn up and
that's of course regrettable which is
why Health ministers are sitting down
listening to the trade unions will
accept the pay review body uh we
accepted the pay review body
recommendations last year and we look
forward to ones this year we're very
committed to delivering on those and
that's why we put a huge amount of extra
resources into the Health Service okay
um let's talk rail strikes shall we
there has been some talk of potential
progress uh this week this is how it's
been reported train operating companies
are set to make a new offer to striking
rail workers this week after receiving a
revised mandate from the government
yeah this is going to sound a bit silly
but what does that actually mean a
revised mandate from the government what
what's happened well it means the train
operating companies have have got
permission from me to make a new offer
to rail Unions that's what they're going
to be doing
um that's what I was asked to do that's
my role in the process but it's
important now that we give some space
for the employers so that's the train
operating companies and network rail to
continue having discussions with the rmt
to try and reach a conclusion you know
we've had two two of the unions have
settled already with network rail I want
to see hopefully the rmt be able to do
so and to settle with the train
operating companies and there are also
um offers and I hope discussion is going
to be underway so the um train operating
companies do need your permission then
to change that or they've got they've
got to revised mandate to to make an
offer to the the trade unions to cover
both pay but all also importantly reform
and as I've said you before you've got
to have pay and reform and they'll be
having those discussions this coming
week on reform is it true that you've
scaled back the insistence on
driver-only operated trains no we we've
been very clear reform's been on the
table all the way through the whole
issue about driver operating trains I
mean they've been in existence frankly
since I was a teenager which I'm afraid
quite a long time ago in the 1980s
um at 55 percent of passengers travel on
trains where driver only operation is
already in place so this isn't a new
thing no general or general position
we're moving more towards that right is
that insistence been dropped our general
position on reform is that reform is
still incredibly important because it's
it's by having generational reform on
the railways both Network Rail and the
train operating companies so we generate
the savings to pay for the pay Awards to
starve and still have a financially
sustainable Railway we um it's
interesting isn't it because we spend an
awful lot of time talking about trains
whether it's rail strikes hs2 but
obviously the majority of Journeys in
the UK taken by bus and also by Road and
do you think that hs2 needs to be
re-looked at it takes an awful lot of
money right well look I think your
general point is is well made and I've
been very clear about that in the
department it's the department for
transport not the department for trains
and I'm very clear that most people for
most of their Journeys travel by Road as
you said either by car or by bus buses
are actually incredibly for important
form of public transport but I think we
we should do all of the things I think
actually hs2 is an important investment
and sometimes people get forget partly
because of the title of it but actually
the most important thing is about the
capacity improvements that it puts so no
change no change so we no no so we the
government's made it clear that
Chancellor made it clear in the in the
awesome statement that the government
remains committed to delivering hs2 it's
about improving the capacity of our rail
network which is important because
otherwise it's going to become congested
in the years to come but that continues
but so does investment in our regular
rail services and also very importantly
in our bus and our road Network um now
just to move on to one of the story
that's been in the uh being covered a
lot today Iran has executed a British
Iranian National after accusing him of
spying for the UK now you've announced
some pretty limited sanctions you've
temporarily withdrawn Britain's
ambassador to Iran for further
consultations
is that it well look the foreign
secretary was very strong in the
language that you used in the language
brutal killing of Mr agbari and
obviously our thoughts are with his
family we've recalled the Ambassador for
consultations and I think the foreign
secretary is going to call in the
Iranian charged Affair their most senior
diplomatic official in the UK to make
our views very clear to the Iranian
government and I know the foreign
secretary is going to be thinking about
what more we can do but we've made our
position very clear in the strongest
possible terms about this brutal act and
it just shows up I think the sort of
regime
that the Iranian government is what kind
of regime are they then well they're a
regime that has treated one of their own
citizens a dual national uh in this
incredibly brutal way and that's not
acceptable which is why as I said the
foreign British governments uh views
very very clear indeed both the foreign
secretary and the Prime Minister made
very clear that this was a brutal act
and that we're going to take further
steps you are going to take further
steps then we're going to think about
what more we can do and using our
diplomatic influence around the world
make it very clear to the Iranians that
this sort of terrible behavior is
unacceptable we've we're opposed to the
death penalty in all circumstances and
we condemn this brutal Act
um now Boris Johnson registered a
donation of a million pounds this week
he's still considering a comeback isn't
he
well I don't know what uh Boris
Johnson's thinking about doing you know
he's out making money on the the
speaking circuit I'm very clear the
prime minister is focused on the
priorities of the British people in
terms of halving inflation growing the
economy cutting NHS waiting lists and
stopping small boats those are the
priorities of the people that's what the
Prime Minister and the government is
focused on that's what we're spending
our time thinking about rather than
thinking about what um former Prime
Ministers do come on though you know
people don't donate a million pounds to
MPS who are just going to be sitting
quietly on the back benches do they well
look the former prime minister is
obviously out and about you know with
speaking engagements but for government
and the prime minister of focus on those
important priorities
it's not outside learning it's a
donation from somebody well look people
are free to donate money to whoever they
like and and as long as those things are
properly registered that's absolutely
fine as I said the Prime Minister and
the government are focused on the
Public's priorities which is what the
public would expect us to be doing is he
a distraction foreign no not really I
said we're focused on our priorities
which is a halving inflation growing the
economy reducing NHS waiting lists and
stopping small boats that's what the
government's focused on every day of the
week and not everyone of course thinks
that Boris Johnson is an asset I just
want to look this is one of the pictures
of the week I have to say from your
previous as transport secretary Grant
chaps there's Boris Johnson there in the
middle of the photo and as if by Magic
hopefully it is coming I promise here we
are he disappears
um
what's going on there well I don't know
you you'd have to ask my uh you'd have
to ask my predecessor what's happened
with his with his social media but look
I think that's one of those little funny
things that happened during the week
that I don't think we need to spend too
much time on but uh very important point
there is our very important focus on our
space program and Britain's ambition to
be a global leader in launching small
satellites I think our Sport's important
um talking to Grant sharp some people
say that Mick Lynch for example the rmt
said that he's still pulling the strings
to the government over the real dispute
not you no well that's not correct I
mean you'll know since I became
transport secretary I met all the Trade
union leaders uh I was very clear about
making sure we had a new and improved uh
Fair reasonable offer on the table and
both myself and the rail Minister Hugh
Merriman have been facilitating talks
with the rail unions which is why I
think we've made some progress and I
hope we can make further progress I want
to stop these damaging disputes they're
bad for people who work on the railways
and they've had most importantly for
passengers and The Wider economy so I
think we made a big change since I
became transport search and I hope to
make continued progress are you
optimistic then well look I I very much
hope we can get to a solution to these
rail businesses
I hope we can I've made the changes that
I think uh are necessary to get us on a
path to that and I said the trade unions
and the employers are having detailed
discussions and I think it's important
that we give them some space to
hopefully hammer out an agreement that
can be put before union members and be
accepted okay you very much indeed
pleasure